今天台灣股市有點
好像開高以後又有點走低
結果最後只漲46點
很多人想要知道說
三大重點 來
台灣股市46000為什麼站不穩
是不是像我標題寫的
你要先走 先走一趟再說
真的要先走一趟嗎
第二個 精材法說會變成法會
接下來很多公司的法說會
也會這樣嗎
鴻海法說會
好像也有點變法會了
怎麼都會這樣子呢
第三 週三台指期結算
是要壓低還是拉高結算
今天這三大重點
還有一些股票
為什麼現在停滯不前
我今天要獨家通通告訴你
還有被動元件
跟記憶體的未來
一次給你說個夠
台股今天早盤盤中
再度站上46000
最後小漲了46點
收漲在45857點
上週五美股指數全收黑
今天台股還是照樣漲給你看
真的太強啦
而投資長的選美小姐
環球晶這檔股票
上週連續2天漲停
重新站回千元大關
今天又開高急拉
股價大漲接近漲停
中美晶股價也上漲快3%
不過今天投資朋友們最好奇的
一定就是一開盤就打到跌停的精材
到底發生什麼事了
難道投資長說的無敵買點又出現了嗎
你手上還沒有飆股嗎
接下來就交給我們
經濟日報選股冠軍
單季188%的紀錄保持者
同時也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
最受歡迎的分析師
郭哲榮投資長 投資長好
Lily 各位投資朋友大家好
今天行情還不錯
說不錯也沒有到很好
因為上櫃指數有點下跌
有些股票有點跌下去
環球晶看起來要拉上漲停
又殺下去
大家現在還在匍匐前進
怎麼會這樣
其實結算都是會這樣子
連今天結算都不算一個當沖順勢盤
都沒有一路走高走低
但是明天有機會 好不好
今天期貨做得沒有到非常順
雖然之前我們賺了4000點
現在開始要做一些當沖
今天比較沒有一路走高
或一路走低的態勢
明天有機會
先跟大家講 好不好
那今天的行情 我們來看一下
今天行情先講一下
聽說哲哲最近很紅
Threads 然後臉書都很紅 真的
連什麼
說哲哲化身為愛情大師
連Joeman 陳幸妤的事件
每個人都用我的梗圖
來說明這一切
但是我覺得
等一下我跟你講我的想法 是
這個先不講 這個喇低賽而已
我們先來看一下這些股票
我們先來講一下
今天我們有一檔股票跌
譬如說微星
今天微星拉起來以後對不對
又殺下去對不對 對
微星也不要
去追高的過程中要注意一下
至少不要去追最高
那微星是這樣子 還有什麼
還有我們來看一下
還有一檔股票
一個是2377 一個2376
兩兄弟有沒有看到
一追高就殺下去
你知道為什麼微星跟技嘉
創新高過後
微星跟技嘉創新高過後會拉回嗎
因為很簡單
因為現在95%
甚至98%的股票
都還在谷底翻轉
我問你一件事情
今天如果國巨到1200
你現在國巨到1200
其他股票都破底
你會不會想賣掉1200的國巨 會
這樣答案不就出來了
我再講一次
現在國巨不在600塊
是在1200
那其他的股票
記憶體很多股票在破底
其他的被動元件在破底
可是只有國巨還在高檔
你會不會出掉1200的國巨 會喔
並不是因為你知道他會跌到600元
而是你知道
如果再跌下去他會很恐怖
這時候你們很理性 再講一次
如果今天國巨是一路漲
你不知道他一定會跌到600元
或跌到500元
可是你在1200的時候
現在國巨如果是1200
你鐵定會賣
因為太多股票在破底翻
你懂我的意思嗎
你看環球晶
他也是從1600怎麼樣
跌到這個700多元對不對 對
是不是沒錯
1600跌到700多元 打對折
現在反彈起來也還好而已
所以很多股票如果創新高
大家第一件事就想賣
然後隔日沖的人見好就收
或當沖的人見好就收
所以微星就這樣子被利用了
技嘉也就這樣被利用了 懂不懂
技嘉今天跌停板很正常
來看一下我們當初的重播
你就知道哲哲講在前面好不好
我們來看一下
一切的一切哲哲預告在前面 來
我們來看一下 來
放一下
以後請
今天是助理
助理應該是有
快考上分析師資格
應該有分析師資格
這次考上就沒問題了
雖然我們有分析師資格
但還是要講一下
助理要記得
最近助理不在
重播要播前幾秒
因為剛才前幾秒播追高
沒事 這是我跟他的對話
你們不要理我
就是他重播的時間是不對的
來 我們來看一下
沒關係 還是一樣有重點
當我碎碎念 這不是重點
大家來看一下 來
微星追高又不行了
因為他是少數創新高的股票
又不行了
技嘉也是一樣啊 是不是
2376是不是
也是一樣啊
你說這邊追高好不好
不要 抱著就好
為什麼不要追高
為什麼不要追高有沒有看到 有
我是不是有講為什麼不要追高
為什麼不要買技嘉 不要買仁寶
為什麼不要追高
我有沒有講 有啊 是不是
不要買仁寶
這個我剛才已經重複了
聽清楚喔
不要買技嘉 不要買仁寶
微星你不要去追高
有沒有講 有
好恐怖喔
因為如果你現在一堆股票
都還在套牢中
解套無期的時候
你會要的是一個
現在怎麼賣都會賺錢的股票
你會賣一個
你懂不懂
所以微星 技嘉就會被殺下來
這樣懂不懂
因為創新高 懂不懂
現在台灣股市還沒有突破5萬
還沒有突破48000的時候
創新高就會怎樣
打地鼠 把他打下去了
這樣懂不懂
哪個分析師有告訴你這個東西
這是獨家的
哲哲不是只會講幹話而已
你知不知道 好不好
這個跟大家講
很多人還說
哲哲 像今天不是那個什麼
有人說哲哲你是完美的男人
有人現在講到我
我講一下
可是我要告訴大家
這個講八卦 聊天而已
有人說喜歡Joeman
不如喜歡郭哲榮
最近不是Joeman
或是陳幸妤
他的老公 趙建銘事件
都是這個事情
都是什麼事情
就是兩個人愛情糾紛
喜歡Joeman不如喜歡郭哲榮
我先跟大家講
我對Joeman這個事情
我不想要特別表示意見
當然可以不用扯到哲哲
你看哲哲的說明就說了一切
我自己寫的
很多人還覺得不是我自己寫的
不要怎樣
害我要變成自我介紹
不要踩別人去捧我
拜託 各位網友們
不要因為我現在有點閱率
我是蠻大方的一個人
大家問就知道了
但是我是大男人
我心地應該算好
但是脾氣不敢說很好
有時候我也在教別人過程中
我有時候
比如說教同仁的過程中
有時候我脾氣有點暴躁
如果重複一直重複的話
但是我絕對不是壞人
我自認為我絕對不是壞人
但是就像我說的
不用把我當偶像
重點是投資績效好
如果投資績效不好
說老實話 我是金城武
真的你不會看
如果投資績效很好 我是醜男
你們還是會看
所以投資朋友
不需要把這兩個人扯在這邊
可是說感情前面
我有一個想法
大家參考一下好不好
尤其我們7成是男性
雖然我最近多很多女性
男生我教大家一個東西
第一個
雖然網路上常常跟你講要AA制
盡量不要AA制 你有沒有看到
你看趙建銘 有沒有看到
跟那個Joeman
你看AA制了
就出事了嘛
我說實在話啦
不是 我不是在噹他們
這叫做人生厚黑學
你有能力
你沒能力就算了
你沒能力要跟他AA沒關係
可是你沒能力
男生真的很可憐
我覺得男生真的很可憐
身為男生我覺得很可憐
我也不是噹那些AA制的男生
就像我講Lily
Lily 男生十個裡面
有九個男生都要幫他付錢
一個要AA制的
九個裡面也很優秀
也有潛在實力
說不定現在沒有很有錢
但是九個男生裡面有願意付錢的
大部分的人
如果你們是Lily
你們還是會選
那九個願意幫他出錢的男生
沒有錯嘛
不能說你市儈
而是這是人性啊 你懂不懂
如果你是男生
你十個女生裡面
有九個女生倒追你
然後願意幫你出錢
你一定會選那九個裡面嘛
不會選那一個嘛
所以男生很可憐
能不要AA制就不要AA制
沒有辦法
雖然你們覺得這樣
要AA制能找到真愛
你看這兩個都跟人家A嘛
A下去了 是不是
我就講 為什麼
我再教大家一個人生厚黑學
這也是股市一樣 見好就收
為什麼有時候我魚尾給人家
我國巨也是一樣啊
為什麼我6 700元我就走了
後來1200我不理他
我等到4 500元我再買
我留一點給人家賺
你在感情世界裡面
你也留一點給人家賺
你不需要跟人家計較那麼多
來 我再教大家一件事情
尤其有些我們在這邊
蠻多是有社會地位的
工程師或者家裡有錢的
或者是你本來就有地位的
男生也好 女生也好
留點餘地給人家
再講一次 留點餘地給人家
愛情的世界裡面
為什麼對方有時候會報復他
我告訴大家 學起來喔
這連股票市場也可以學到喔
因為就是馬雲說的
馬雲說的是對員工
其實對愛情也是一樣
人家要離開
就是要嘛就怎麼樣
要嘛心委屈了 要嘛錢委屈
有沒有聽過這句話 有
我再送你一個進階版本
對方 分手的對方
會報復你 通常就是怎麼樣
記得喔
通常是心也委屈了 錢也委屈了
員工是其中一個 他可能會走
可是對方會報復你是兩個都委屈了
記起來
你趙建銘也好
你跟人家分手了 離婚分手
如果你給人家多一點錢
什麼教育基金啊 房貸不要人家背
你多個幾千萬
聽說他年收入不只幾千萬
你不要在乎那個錢
人家陳幸妤也不會爆你 是不是
Joeman這個事情
我不是要噹他 我是講事情
如果你那時候願意大方一點點 是不是
雖然他的人品 有人覺得人品
這個我不知道
因為他講的 對方講的
我不去講這些
可是這兩個都委屈的情況下
你心也委屈 你對人家不夠好
錢也委屈了
就很容易被人家爆料 這樣懂不懂
這樣懂不懂 這懂我的意思嗎
這是我跟大家講的
所以教大家一個心態
股市也是一樣 你不要什麼都拿
你錢也要
心也要給他佔據住
錢也要跟他佔據住了
你心要讓人家委屈
錢也要讓人家委屈 這就不行
這樣懂不懂 這樣不行 OK嗎
有沒有學到這個股市的厚黑學
跟愛情的厚黑學
股票也是一樣嘛
不要什麼都要全拿嘛
哲哲 我要賣在最高點
那這個東西
我說我賣最高點 你怎麼沒有賣
哲哲你很會講啦 不要追啦
那你為什麼不最高點賣 你很遜耶
你們就是典型的什麼都要
如果你們這樣對我要求
那不好意思 我沒辦法
就像我講的 很多網路上有人批評我
我從來沒說過我沒有賠錢 我不懂耶
分析師就是給投資建議啊
再講一件事
如果你要郭哲榮把把贏
不要看我的節目
可是你要我實在的跟你講這些東西
我可以很實在的跟你講
本來就是投資顧問
這有什麼好講的 是不是
也是一樣啊
現在很多人把我當完人耶
拿Joeman跟我比
我覺得不用踩誰捧誰
我現在也不是要踩他捧他
我只是教大家
或者他有看到我的節目
告訴他以後記得這件事
我跟你講真的 你會發現到
台灣女生其實蠻厚道的
基本上你不要這兩個都委屈
不要錢也委屈 心也委屈
人家不會跟你亂搞這些東西
一樣 股市也是一樣
留一點給人家賺 來看一下
所以男生啦 知道嗎
男生女生都是一樣
台灣男生比較可憐一點
男生女生都一樣
留一點路給別人
就是留一點路給自己
在這邊 我留一點給人家賺怎麼樣
6 700怎麼樣
後面 哲哲你好遜喔
後面給人家賺嘛 是不是
如果我跟你講說
我真的賣在1200
你反而來不及走 你知道嗎
所以我留一點給你們賺有什麼不好
是不是 是
多賺一點也沒差
那等到500的時候
400多的時候
我再買不是很漂亮 是不是
我這一段沒賺到又怎麼樣
我這一段賺到就好了 投資朋友
我這一段賺到就好了
我不需要賺這一段啦
留點面子 留點情面
留點錢給人家賺
開心 是不是
這就是答案 開心
愛情跟股市一樣
他還說凌晨4點有沒有煮麵給人家吃
我不去批評人家這件事情
我不去講他的事
可是這是我的想法 你看一下
來 注意一下
我不會凌晨4點叫你下麵給我吃
你不要想歪 好不好
這個真的是
叫他凌晨4點煮牛肉麵給人家吃嘛
對不對
好像Joeman有這個事情
你有看這個新聞嗎 有
我不會凌晨4點叫你下麵給我吃
但是我覺得有時候情侶吵架
有時候不一定
有時候只是氣話而已
這不代表他要做的
可是我要跟大家講
我要講一件事 我沒有要批評男生
我覺得感情的世界裡面
沒有絕對的對跟錯
可是你要注意一下
你不要讓人家錢也委屈了
心也委屈了 很重要
也不是說用錢就能打發一切
No no no 我不是這樣講
我只是講說一個股市厚黑學
你不要逼人家到一個絕境
這樣懂嗎
好 愛情股市厚黑學
我不會凌晨4點叫
來 注意一下 再講一次
我不會凌晨4點叫你下麵給我吃
但我會凌晨4點寫解盤文章給你
有吧 很多次吧
當分析師20年好幾次
幾十次都有 上百次都有
再講一次
我不會凌晨4點叫你下麵給我吃
不需要念大家
但是相對的我會服務大家
我會凌晨4點寫解盤文章給你
by Kobe哲哲
為什麼Kobe哲哲
Kobe Bryant NBA的名將
雖然去世了 但是他說過了
你有沒有看過凌晨4點的LA洛杉磯
因為他是凌晨4點開始練球
我是凌晨4點寫解盤文章給你
大家共勉之
好不好 OK嗎
這個開玩笑的
不是開玩笑
這個有可能 大家可能有要截圖
截圖了好不好
那沒關係
你要截就隨便你
OK 這個跟大家講
來看一下
記得一件事
我都開玩笑說
以後我那個過馬路
如果老奶奶我不扶的話
不扶她的話
大家會覺得我人是不是不夠好
選分析師 不會啦
不是選完美人格好不好 是
來 笑死了 人數變多了
錢委屈 心委屈
收穫愛情秘訣
本來就是 謝謝大家
有沒有梗 有梗
開黃腔 不是啊
這是真的牛肉麵給大家吃
凌晨4點煮牛肉麵
他這個Joeman
叫人家凌晨4點煮麵
可是我要講一件事
有可能他們前面的對話
其實大家如果有交往過都知道
有時候這個氣話
不代表真的要這樣做
也不代表這邊有PUA 情勒
我剛才只是開玩笑
我的重點是
我不管人家有沒有凌晨叫人家下麵
下牛肉麵給人家吃
我會凌晨4點寫文章給你
好不好 OK嗎
惹人愛不需要做過多解釋
沒有啦 這開玩笑而已
順便聊一下而已 好不好 來
我女友凌晨4點多
你這個會不會太黃 好不好
仁寶這次回檔可以買嗎
仁寶也回檔嘛 對不對
所以你看
我是不是說
我剛才重播是不是有講仁寶
對不對 Lily沒錯吧 有
仁寶不要追有沒有講 你看
現在這種行情真的很狠
隔日沖他沒有買盤
第一個隔日沖他沒有買盤
當沖或隔日沖他沒有買盤
他明天就不計代價地走
為什麼沒有買盤
因為大家不想追
行情不夠好 量不夠多
現在很多散戶還在受傷
我現在還在套牢
為什麼我要追下一個股票
散戶 我說散戶
我跟大家講說
如果你1200
你拜託你500元買一張
1700你850就平
5 600元買一張
你850怎麼樣
就已經回本了
不是 大家就是不想
也不想再放了
也沒有錢了
很多一半是沒有錢
一半是不想買
那等到解套他才會沖
他才會換股票
那這陣子沒有換股票的過程中
誰要去沖仁寶
誰要去沖那個技嘉
所以你創新高
隔天就沒有買盤 就殺下去了
你看我這些邏輯都跟大家講好不好
這個跟大家講
以前股市遇大事
哲哲清晨都會寫文章
現在比較少
因為我年紀大了
對 你們沒錯
你看都是哲粉
因為我要的是身心靈的健康
你懂我意思嗎 OK嗎
所以跟人家喇低賽 開開玩笑
可是我要的是什麼
我要的是跟大家
我現在已經20年股市了對不對
我期望我能在股市
再做20年到30年
做到我離開人世的這一刻
我一直在享受這個股市 你懂不懂
享受跟你的對話
你懂不懂我的意思 OK嗎
來 哲哲都有講
哲神雖然欣興 全新不是你的股票
可以稍微說看看嗎
好 看一下
來 中美晶 精材怎麼了
精材等一下一起講好不好
我們先來看一下 好不好
哲哲去過哪些國家
你們可不可以
我剛才已經暗示你們了
重點是投資
我不太喜歡跟大家講我太多的事情
像之前我講過我一次我過動兒
過動症啊 怎麼樣
發現自己的過程
沒想到還有記者都知道
就是因為採訪我的太多了 你懂不懂
還有就是我節目上有時候會喇低賽
有時候我其實沒有
沒有那麼喜歡講那麼多事情好不好
去哪些國家
我大部分 我能講的就是
我大部分都去5天內的國家
我很少 不太喜歡去歐美
因為我是工作狂怎麼去歐美
你懂我的意思嗎
而且我覺得去過歐美幾次以後
就覺得那不是自己的國家
你懂不懂
講難聽一點就是
你去歐美 人家看你的感覺
就有些台灣人是看越南
看菲律賓 看印度人的感覺
就是這感覺而已
那你幹嘛看呢
你懂嗎 你幹嘛去呢 OK嗎
沒有隱私的
沒有 我是分析師
還是希望有一點隱私 OK嗎 來
分析師重點是投資
我又不是網紅
靠大家的那個
靠大家喜不喜歡 好不好 OK
好啦 哲神我愛你
整天推薦別人來
你很愛我 你整天推薦別人來看我
力積電 你都這樣講
你都這樣捧我 捧成這樣子
我看一下好不好
力積電
我就講
力積電跟那個
我比較想要華邦電
第一個 華邦電跌比較深一點點
看起來 如果我沒看錯的話
用看的話
力積電還沒跌那麼深
力積電快平前高有沒有看到
離前高是不是很近 是
用看的就知道
有些用看的就知道 好不好
所以看圖說故事
有時候解盤看一下就好了
然後看一下
有沒有在均線之上
這是均線
在季線之上 季線之下
你懂不懂
在季線之上已經一段時間了
這個離季線之上比較近
有沒有看到 有
所以他反彈沒那麼多
這樣學會了沒 好不好
那我們先來看一下
我們今天的恭賀簡訊
我喝個水
請Lily念一下好不好
等一下 來喔
環球晶今天一度8%
之前一根 兩根漲停板
恭喜念一下好不好
今天的簡訊 來
8月17號星期一早上10點39分
恭喜6488環球晶
開低走高一路急拉
股價大漲快8%
我們買進到現在
最高已經大賺99%
我持續看好他 手上持股獲利續抱
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
恭喜大家賺大錢 來
恭喜6488環球晶
開低走高一路急拉
股價大漲快8%
我們買進到現在
最高已經大賺99%
我持續看好他 手上持股獲利續抱
投資朋友 這是環球晶
賺99%
可是我很貪心
之前賺到快170%我還沒走
還是快200%
你們知道1600的時候沒有走
我就是認為他有機會2000元
但是他的EPS
沒辦法這麼快的增加
這是可惜之處
可是你要想一件事
就是EPS沒辦法那麼快增加
如果像記憶體
你都知道EPS很好了
然後你就算的出來EPS了
你聽得懂嗎 是
然後廣達 緯創算出來EPS
就沒有爆發啦 你懂我的意思嗎
ABF載板知道缺貨了
所以等到環球晶
看起來準備 記起來
準備從缺貨
有點缺變成非常缺的過程中
從有點缺變成非常缺
變成有EPS的時候
到有EPS的時候變成股價動不了
再講一次
股價三部曲是這樣子
本來不缺貨
應該說四部曲
變成缺貨 股價會先漲一段 是
然後 再講一次喔
東西不缺貨 產品不缺貨
不會動嘛
從產品不缺貨
變成有點缺貨的時候
股價會先動
有時候先漲3 40%
現在環球晶已經漲很多了
來 四個步驟
不缺貨變成缺貨
這時候漲很多
漲最多的是從缺貨變成非常缺貨
這樣懂不懂
然後再變成有EPS
EPS真的出現的時候
EPS出現的時候反而股價不動
你看廣達 緯創
都已經漲完啦
你看 你們要冷靜
他就麻煩了
你看鴻海多少錢
鴻海以前
去年的時候才150而已有沒有看到
你聽得懂嗎
Lily懂我的意思嗎 懂
去年的時候才150
去年更低有到110有沒有看到
這是110有沒有看到
110這邊過去
所以我要講的是說
股價 環球晶
接下來你這個時候是最完美的時候
等到算出來EPS大幅度增加的時候
他已經2000 3000了
懂我在說什麼嗎 好不好
隨著記憶體擴增他會缺貨
記得我這句話 好不好
慢慢跟大家講
還有 再慢慢看
來 我們看一下
還有我們剛剛講精材
精材也是一樣
精材就是他現在EPS還沒出來
這是好事也是壞事
精材為什麼跌停板
精材比較不一樣
因為精材法說會不太好
毛利率下滑了 29.7%
又沒到很高 變成27.7%
好不好 OK嗎
這個跟大家講
因為他的資本支出有沒有看到
折舊增加了有沒有看到 有
還有記憶體短缺
漲價可能影響終端需求 好不好
重點是Q2的毛利率季減
還有這是什麼
12吋的CIS延後了有沒有看到
新案量產推遲到2027年上半年
這個有點久
等於推遲半年了
這是最大的問題
測試服務為主力
我覺得他的EPS不夠漂亮
所以今天跌停很正常 好
這一次的跌停我們來去看一下
富貴險中求
接下來我們要看精材
這個跌停
明天再一根
250 260可不可以打開
如果250 260
確定這邊是底部了
那可以追一下
因為之前250直接拉起來對不對 對
精材裡面背後
還是有中實戶 大戶在拉他
看得出來好不好
我覺得他可能是最後的題材了
當然市場上也傳出來說
台積電會賣他
我不去預測還沒有發生的事情
那太痛苦了
那台積電要不要再減碼世界
你問這些問題沒有意思
你懂我的意思嗎
你聽得懂我的邏輯嗎 懂
回到這個重點
技術線型250可不可以有支撐
第二個回到重點 來
技術線型回到250了
是不是再回檔40%
這就是我一直強調
為什麼我現在不去追高
因為台灣股市混沌不明
你有沒有發現到
彈到46000
該彈的都彈了
都先彈30%了
所以創新高的股票不好
因為彈3 40% 我問你
國巨最多彈好像快40%對不對
是不是 對
可是有彈很多嗎
你看就好了
感覺沒有
你看就好 有彈很多嗎
沒有啊
可是這樣已經37%了
所以代表大家都套牢
你懂不懂我的意思 是
很扯喔 這才37%
如果我沒記錯的話
當分析師數字要很好
數字的記憶力也要很好
我記憶力不算好
記憶力不算非常好
但是數字的記憶力還滿好的
正37%
Understand嗎
正37% 所以我要說的是什麼
我要說的是 你看一下
在這邊看起來彈很多
但其實還差很多
很多還是沒有解套 OK嗎
所以現在不要去追高
去追這種來回做價差的股票
OK 懂不懂
我說800元以上就有很多壓力
沒想到現在700元左右
就先有壓力了 是
還算弱勢反彈
但也是創造買點
再講一件事
5萬點有機會
轉折已經46000了
只是5萬點有機會
散戶的信心能不能回到5萬點
能不能回到48000
還需要慢慢的熬
這樣懂不懂我的意思 懂
精材剛才講這個東西
精材就是看技術線型 OK嗎
中美晶能到500嗎
有沒有很貪心
中美晶先300好不好
現在100幾 186
400有機會 我覺得400有機會
但是我覺得環球晶
我比較看好環球晶
我先看環球晶2000好不好
環球晶2000的話 基本上它
300元應該有機會
這個我比較OK 好不好
來 心與錢都委屈才會爆料
是真的啊 你留一點給人家
不論你是不要讓人家委屈
錢很小氣
當他對你很好 他就不會爆了
他對我很差
但是對方有一筆錢給你
是不是 你爆了
對方爆了也會覺得說
沒有啊 對方對你還是有不錯啊
有些人想法是這樣子
都委屈了才會爆料 就是這樣
前提就是告訴大家
日後要留一線
做什麼事都是一樣
做股票也是一樣
留一點給人家賺 這樣懂不懂
這是股市的厚黑學
股市愛情厚黑學 好不好 好啦
來 中美晶 環球晶打底
哲哲寶貝
0050可以加碼嗎
0050 Anytime Anywhere
我再給你講一次
那是我像神仙神明般的操作
可以買到最低點
你們不是 不要學
你們要做就是有錢
如果你們不想買股票
有錢就買台灣50
很多粉絲是因為這樣
才跟我十幾年了
有錢買台灣50
然後突然有一筆
然後有時候有閒錢
或者突然你知道
譬如說你可以稍微動用理財型房貸
你知道你還得起那個理財型房貸
比如說你有1億的身價
理財型房貸有1000萬額度
那或許你可以增貸 或許
可是我沒有建議
因為我不知道你的情況
你不要拖到我身上
沒辦法 真的
可是或許你可以
就是你本來就有閒錢 平常在買
然後突然你看到我怎麼樣
買台灣50的時候
你就去湊錢
跟我一樣去買台灣50
人家有人說
有人說我股票操作很厲害
又有人說我股票還好
但是哲哲用自己的錢買台灣50的時候
是一定要跟
很多人在網路上謠傳
網路上江湖傳言
不是江湖傳言
已經變江湖的事實了 OK嗎
台積電本益比只有22倍
環球妖精憑什麼2000
所以我就說
要等EPS慢慢出現
不要急 好不好 OK嗎
房子不要贈與配偶
不是這個重點 重點是
那個趙建銘對
陳幸妤覺得趙建銘對他不夠好
是不是
花心就算了
連最後小孩子的錢
房子的贈與
這些錢都跟我計較
是這些 是感覺問題 懂嗎
OK嗎 來
這個跟大家講
國巨要拉大家了
哲哲要普發1萬了 1萬能買什麼
你不要再講普發了
上次普發1萬我忘記拿了
我真的為你們少賺很多 你知道嗎
我上個月才想到 普發耶
我發現前幾個月就已經截止了
怎麼辦
沒怎麼辦 就是愛你們的代價
反正 我如果每天想這些
我是不是很難過
我如果想著每一個的錢都要賺
每個錢都要計較
我很痛苦 是不是
我每個錢都要計較
那不好意思
到最後反而犧牲的是會員權益
我這樣想就好了
就是我愛大家嘛 好不好
這個跟大家講 來
哲哲很跟得上時事 來
投資長 執行長
可以分析一下世界先進嗎 來
世界先進喔
世界先進也是一樣都沒什麼漲
我跟你講等到這些股票
上櫃股票
他可能突然有一天拉出去了
有可能現在46000
有可能到47000 48000
上櫃指數才整個噴出去
因為上櫃指數太多套牢賣壓
你都不要擔心
這邊只要拉回
再講一件事
其實為什麼我今年績效特別好
你知道嗎 網路上有人說
哲哲你什麼
還有網路上亂講我
一看就知道很多同業
什麼2018年哲哲因為國巨事件
然後就停播了 莫名其妙
不是嘛 離開前一家要成立摩爾
是不是需要時間
那是不是要把原本的節目給停掉 是
那跟國巨有什麼關係
然後哲哲
我這邊也公開可以講
2021年 2022年
就是那個長榮海運跌下來的過程中
上去我有賺錢喔
哲哲 下去的時候你賠很多
我記得後來我把它賺回來
你懂不懂
斷章取義我的話能怎麼辦
可是我要告訴大家
我覺得一件事情
我投資股市20年
不是投資股市 當分析師快20年
投資股市不只
當分析師快20年
怎麼可能天天賺
你要天天賺 你找別人
那你被騙剛好
我就跟大家講 不可能
所以網路上有些人
有什麼黑我的
大部分 當然有些是網友
有些是會員
更多的是同業
聽聽就好了 OK嗎
他們用批評郭哲榮的標準
沒有人能活
當然我還是要講一件事
不喜歡都可以不要看我的節目
我不勉強 哲哲不缺錢
哲哲現在也不是為了錢
你看我連普發1萬都忘記了
那個去ATM一下就好了
真的太忙了 我真的太忙了 是不是
所以我覺得很多人詆毀我
讓他們公司業績變好
隨便 我沒差 你聽得懂嗎
第一個 也不會增加
你懂我的意思嗎 懂
也不會增加
第二個 我有沒有做我都很平常心
因為我在股市我可以賺錢
你懂不懂
最差不當分析師 我說實在話
我認為也很難
我也很難被取代
因為我跟人家不太一樣
說老實話 這不是臭美
可是最差不當分析師
我也覺得沒差
因為我就每天講我該講的東西
反而不會被限制那麼多
你會發現到更誇張
如果當網紅 我跟你講
我比那些網紅 都完全不是我的對手
基本上已經很多人覺得我是網紅
可是我不一樣好不好
我說財經網紅
我會比他們講得更誇張 OK嗎
因為我就沒有受限 你知道嗎
我們現在還是得遵守
主管機關的要求 OK嗎
但是我可以確定一件事
不敢說我是完美的人
但是投資的誠信
我自認為我應該接近100分
我絕對不會故意害大家賠錢 OK嗎
我也不會自己偷買股票
這一回事 記得這件事
而且你們賠錢
我是絕對很難過 很不開心
你們賺錢 我比你們還開心
這是我可以確定的事情
好不好 OK嗎 來
旺宏 台虹
這個感覺是這樣子
Lily會煮牛肉麵嗎 你要問他
來 先跟大家講
哲哲還要忙著當社區主委
對 我們這棟大樓就是社區主委
重複一直洗版的就會被刪掉
或者是暫停講話
你們這些人都是新朋友
都不是舊朋友 不理你們
今天直播人數7000人
現在幾分了
34 最近比較無聊
我想了一些好玩的梗
不然很快錄完了
來 我們來看一下南亞科
南亞科裡面的中實戶很強
當然我還是最喜歡群聯
我今年為什麼績效好 很簡單
怎麼樣
不去追多
南亞科我不去追多 好不好
南亞科會不會漲到1000塊
有可能 這種漲法有可能1000塊
但是漲1000塊就一倍而已
我不在乎 今年我很多
就像我講的
愛情跟股市的故事是一樣
不要全部都要
你不要讓對方全部都委屈
也是一樣
股票你不要全部都要
這個追高
南亞科我可能進場
但是絕對是他
至少目前我跟你講 目前我看到
絕對是拉回我才進場
追高我不想
因為太多股票現在追高不好
就像我講的
你現在股票只有他一枝獨秀創新高
講好聽一點是有大戶在拱
可是講難聽一點
會很多人想要賣他 是
我說檯面上有的人
自有的股份他會想要賣他
你聽得懂嗎 懂
有一些有股份的
有股票 股東的這些散戶
持有股票的這些散戶
會有賣壓
因為只有他讓我賺錢
他會覺得只有他讓我賺錢
會有賣壓
中實戶 大戶扛不太上去
這樣懂不懂
當然這裡面的中實戶 大戶
已經很有名了
他其實資金應該1 200億以上
那當然他還是可以扛
只是問題是如果行情不好
南亞科會跌得比誰都凶
記得這句話
真的喔 會
因為再講一次
你看南亞科要創新高
你看群聯還沒有
股王耶
我講的是 不是股王
獲利股王 OK嗎
是不是 今年上半年EPS他最漂亮
然後上禮拜跌停板
有什麼好跌停板
人家說毛利可能下滑
所以你看今天群聯就拉起來了
好不好 群聯我OK
群聯就算我錯了
最後世界先進比較厲害 我沒差
他強任他強 清風拂山岡
不要想那麼多
本來無一物 何處惹塵埃
你知道嗎 所以我很平常心
也是因為這樣我今年績效很好
然後網友有些就很好笑
一定要講我去年 前年的績效
照你這樣講我都不要當分析師了
講我2022年的績效
怎麼不講我2023年或什麼的績效呢
是不是 講不完啦 好不好
人在做天在看
至少我發自內心
希望我的會員粉絲們賺錢 好不好 來
今天還有什麼股票我們看一下
該講的都講完了
對 我們AI的圖今天講一下
我們還是有做一些AI圖 來
我們來看7月的零售
意外月減0.6%有沒有看到
7月的零售本來是預期
本來前月是0.25%有沒有看到
很多人說零售怎麼樣
衰退了會不會不好
其實跟去年比較還是增加 你懂不懂
就是月增率
月增率跟上個月比
代表是有點下滑
代表景氣的確沒那麼好
我在網路上 什麼河道上
Threads也都在講說
愛馬仕現在不用配貨
的確 現在譬如說
台灣的手錶業者
現在很多都在
都譬如說之前
買那些國外的 國外商品 平行商品
現在其實很多業績不太好 為什麼
因為譬如說像勞力士
台灣勞力士不可能打折
中國勞力士已經打95折了
很扯吧 有這種事情
中國本來就景氣很差
中國賓士被打到不行
中國賓士比台灣便宜100萬
每一台車都比台灣便宜100萬
銷售量還下滑4 50%以上
中國現在很不景氣
中國的確現在很不景氣
所以那中國不景氣怎麼辦
那中國的愛馬仕
中國的Daytona的那個賓士
或者是中國什麼
手錶 奢侈品嗎
奢侈品也會傾銷來台灣 好不好
我的意思是說 這扯遠了
零售數據的確有些不好 好不好
我講的不只中國
現在是看美國
那景氣本來就上上下下 不可能
從2020年到現在已經很好了
你知道嗎 要不是AI有拉起來
所以零售數據不好
那代表也比較不會升息
對股市是好的
零售數據太好的話就會通膨起來
就會要升息降溫了
有沒有看到 OK嗎
所以FedWatch 9月升息機率大減
就是雖然怎麼樣
石油很缺 對不對
石油還是缺 對
美國的戰備儲量
還是創一個近幾十年的新低
因為荷姆茲海峽還是被掐住
被受困住了 被管制住了
可是我石油是不是供給變少了
可是我需求也變少了
供給變少 需求也變少
兩個在這情況之下的話
油價就不會漲那麼凶
所以有人說景氣沒那麼好
景氣沒那麼好 股市反而是好
景氣太好反而要升息
股市重點是要資金
升息對股市是不好
好不好 OK嗎
這樣懂我的意思嗎
好 我們再看一下
還有就是NVIDIA的一個
重金布局生態鏈
很多人講這些
就講一些舊消息
什麼投資什麼生態鏈
就變少了 我不聽了
台灣的股市為什麼會拉起來
超額儲蓄明年估11兆
其實我現在看
台灣人越來越有錢了
因為我在看中秋節要去哪邊玩
機票都被訂滿了
現在有錢人很多
所以我有錢也沒什麼好開心的
所以投資朋友
你要趕快趕上有錢人的步驟
這一波就是很多人靠股市變成有錢的
1億的人好像真的好幾萬人
1億身家的人
懂不懂 他們就敢消費 敢怎麼樣
所以台灣股市
會讓它有動力的原因是因為
太多人變成很有錢
超額儲蓄明年估11兆有沒有看到
人均GDP從28000變成49000
你不覺得這個薪水
光GDP差多少
很扯吧 是不是
真的耶
有沒有想到 為什麼
都是很多半導體業的
或AI相關產業的人怎麼樣
大增有沒有看到
AI產業的人怎麼樣
你看2021年的時候有沒有看到
才31110元有沒有看到
現在邁向5萬美元
你有沒有覺得很奇怪
莫名其妙 跟我什麼關係
是不是
這個就想到一個低級的笑話
我不知道該不該講
譬如說
算了 還是不要講
導播知道我要講什麼
譬如說你跟一個女星
平均而言都有一個東西
算了 不要講 這樣講不下去
當我沒說過
我說平均不代表這個有意義 是
我跟郭台銘 這個講比較實在
我跟郭台銘的平均身價是1000億
然後呢
代表我有1000億喔
好像不是這樣子
關我什麼事
對不對 這樣懂嗎
所以人均GDP邁向5萬美元
代表是很多有錢人有錢 懂不懂
很多有錢人有錢 OK嗎
有錢人越來越有錢
所以你要趕上有錢人的時代好不好
趁這邊薪水沒增加
至少股票要增加
可是因為GDP增加那麼多怎麼樣
超額儲蓄有沒有看到
其實這些超額儲蓄
就是未來在股市的錢
有機會再飆起來 好不好 OK嗎
所以大家吃喝玩樂
所以為什麼現在去日本
以前大家都去一線城市
先想到怎麼樣
東京 再不然去大阪
然後頂多去九州
九州變很熱以後
去二線城市
去四國 去名古屋
沖繩都是台灣人
有沒有 越來越有錢的
玩膩了 你懂不懂 是
所以幸好日本跟美國的關係
現在沒有很好
不然全部都講中文了
這樣懂我在說什麼嗎
我希望趕快特斯拉
台灣的政府趕快
大家趕快去留言或怎麼樣
拜託政府趕快通過特斯拉
我很想要環島
特斯拉如果可以自駕的話
我覺得對台灣而言是很方便
你可以環島
不然我去花東
我為什麼要開5 6個小時
我才不想
可是如果自駕車的話
我就可以休息很久了 OK嗎
這個我跟大家講
所以超額儲蓄對股市來說
是有一定的動能好不好
這個11兆美金
對台灣股市一定有一定的動能
記住我講的這些話好不好
我們看今天還有什麼股票
還有什麼股票我們還沒講的
應該都講了吧
世界先進也講了
精材 微星 國巨也是一樣
國巨這種股票拉回來是要買
海公公怎麼秀逗了
就是法說會不太好 好不好
要普發1萬了
我這次會記得
Lily到時候提醒我要拿這1萬 好
來 9月份要去大阪玩太爽了
你說我還是什麼
不是我 我沒有
以前日本很有錢 對啊
以前日本人比我們有錢好幾倍
現在日本人沒錢
所以你要趁這個股市賺錢的時候
你不要 哲哲
在股市我賺一點點就好
No 你要賺很多
因為1990年代日本錢淹腳目
日本錢非常多 你知道嗎
可是現在沒有 你知道嗎
來 台波 沒有這檔股票吧
來 航運有轉強嗎
好啦 沒有什麼問題
通膨 技嘉講過了
未來升息機率
降息還沒有想到
降息代表景氣
如果現在從升息變成降息那不好
如果現在變升息變降息
明明通膨還滿高的
升息變降息那股市要崩了
如果跟你講說變成降息
代表景氣數據不好
它會先崩再說 你懂不懂 是
現在要變降息的話
變成要救股市了 那不對
所以這樣懂我邏輯嗎 記得
所以你看這是20年的經驗 好不好
美國跟伊朗打鬧 好不好
哲哲沒有白髮
一點點 我有一點點
不要給自己那麼大壓力
我都是問我自己
譬如說這件事情
我對得起自己的良心嗎
這件事情我現在壓力會不會太大
這件事情我做得開不開心
我做得不開心不做
當分析師是這樣子嘛
我做得有點累
福利社我做得開心 但是太累了
而且我覺得更有價值是
怎麼去教新的老師
或有部分老師詢問我這些
投資方面或者是節目方面的
我覺得花時間在他們身上比較實在
所以我福利社
幸好晨彥老師有幫我承接起來
做開心的事情
所以我現在跟你們做的事情
很開心好不好
OK嗎 來
來 哲哲寶貝
你一直叫我寶貝
你知道那首歌嗎 寶貝對不起
寶貝對不起 不是不愛你
好 OK嗎
送給這些叫我寶貝的人好不好
沒辦法每個都那麼愛好不好
好啦 喇低賽而已啦
有沒有導播 都是隨便Re的
沒有Re 這個連Re都沒有Re過
所以沒有囉 現在幾分了
突然看到有穿衣服的哲哲
差點認不出來
你是常常看到我脫衣服是不是
好不好 國巨
在620還有救嗎 哲哲寶貝
620喔 620我覺得有救
620 你要想一件事
如果你國巨是620
我跟你講 你贏一堆人
620真的不要緊張
可是620你現在緊張的人
你不要做股票好不好
620很好啦
我覺得你620 你會賺錢的機率很高
好不好 很高
這邊買低檔的股票就OK 好不好
拉回500多我覺得可以進場
如果跌到500多可以進場
會有第二次反彈機會
我覺得第二次反彈機會很高
第一個 AI就是會缺貨
你們一定要記得我的邏輯
AI會缺貨
國巨的問題只是
國巨的問題怎麼樣
只是籌碼太亂
所以你不要期望他1200
我本來就說不會1200
我甚至連800以上我都覺得很難
你懂不懂 800以上
你說1000以上我就覺得很難
800以上就有壓力了
記得我這句話
所以我都講得很清楚 好不好 OK嗎
哲哲現在適合進場美債嗎
美債永遠都不適合 好不好
我繳了1點多億的錢學到一個教訓
你就買 看了很多研究文獻
我以前也聽信別人大家講的
降1%會漲多少%
可是沒關係 很多人說我美債害了他
會講這句話的
基本上完全沒聽我的節目
因為我說美債換成台灣50
不要買美債了 好不好
不要買債券了 OK
旺宏呢 哲寶貝
你們叫我寶貝
我都覺得好不好意思
都覺得好像要回應你們
不要鬧了
今天沒有拍桌子 有什麼好拍的
今天績效就沒有到非常滿意
就環球晶而已
我很老實好不好 OK 來
好啦 不要再玩我了
一直叫我寶貝 寶貝
OK 好
普發1萬要直接送給媽媽領
對 送給媽媽領
來 對媽媽要孝順 好不好
現在有些人就說
說那個父母養小孩
不應該期望小孩
給那個 不是善養費
給那個孝親費
我完全不以為然
當然我覺得有些人
斷章取義我講的話
我覺得能給孝親費是
就像蜘蛛人講的
能力越大責任越大
當然沒有強迫一定要給
但是我鼓勵大家給 你知道嗎
我媽媽以前也是
我出社會的時候也是強迫我給
其實我很不開心
因為我覺得那時候
我快養不活我自己了
可是我現在謝謝他
因為他給我要求
我才會逼我自己賺比較多錢
好不好 OK嗎
這就是這樣子
有時候會激發你的潛能
而且我覺得給得很開開心心
媽媽現在以我為榮
我也覺得 我也以他為榮
我也是很開心 好不好
所以我覺得言教不如身教
扯遠了 好不好
所以孝親費那1萬就給媽媽
我不只 我給我媽媽很好
我對家人有時候就像我講的
不要給人家錢委屈
我對家人 或者是你說
這個感情方面
有時候可能是我
本來我要買個幾萬塊的包包
結果我媽媽可能進去了
變成他買幾十萬的 我一毛都沒買
你也可以問一下Lily對不對
我那時候有跟他講這個八卦
扯遠了 所以對家人好
沒什麼不好
記得大家今天的結論是什麼
對身邊的人多付出一點點 好不好
多付出一點點
不要計較 不要想太多
反而最後你賺更多
現在哲哲就是這樣子
哲哲以前年紀輕的時候
也比較愛計較一點
雖然我覺得我心地不差
但是比較愛計較
越到年紀到的越不計較
反而收穫越多
股市也是一樣
送給大家
有些股票差不多就好
買差不多就好了
你不要計較那幾塊錢
你幾%的 你就受不了
你很計較 你反而股市賺不了錢
你懂我的意思嗎
所以為什麼我這個股市波動
我可以賺那麼多
沒有差啦 差不多就好了
反而賺很多
這送給大家
今天股市愛情哲學
好不好 送給大家
不論對或錯哲哲一切的一切預告在前面
好不好
加我那個 記得一件事
趕快來電洽詢0800668085
或者加我LINE私訊我
還有IG跟Threads
我是以這些為主
s178178
那現在很多人還是
用s178178的圖片
告訴你有社群
我沒有LINE的社群
這是LINE@ 這不是社群
不是2 3個人
兩言三語這樣講話 好不好
所以只有LINE的這個
跟IG Threads這些
以這兩個為主好不好
投資長 我們還有專案
對 還有專案
你看我是不是都沒在做生意 真的
你不講還好 要記得 好不好
來 我們看一下
逆轉188專案
那個導播剩幾分鐘
49差不多剛好結束了
逆轉188專案
歡迎來電洽詢0800668085
或者加我的LINE私訊我
你看今天到現在才專案而已
參加的人很多
到現在才介紹專案
要不要參加隨便你
基本上明後天一定會結束
甚至可能提早結束
不論對或錯哲哲一切的一切預告在前面
去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
也預祝各位能夠賺大錢
Byebye